so four hours of my life gone forever
watch the Oscars I did it for you
granted I did policy for one hour oh did
I drool but still that's three hours of
my life down the toilet now we could
just focus on the political statements
made but we get that stuff instead why
do people like me who really really love
movies really hate the Oscars I grew up
with a 1970s Saturday matinees where you
arrived in the morning and you left when
it's dark Planet of the Apes the Neptune
factor Willard or disaster epochs like
earthquake Poseidon Adventure towering
inferno movies were the escape for a kid
in suburbia when there wasn't much else
but cement playgrounds littered with
pull-tab beer cans
remember those those are great cut
myself a lot but times have changed now
we're being informed not entertained the
Oscars now ignore the escape bowing to
pressures of group groupthink as virtue
signaling Trump's shared human
experience movies were once about
entertaining us yet the Oscars recast
art as a conduit for the new religion of
identity none other than President Trump
called get out the best first
three-quarters of a movie this year we
don't make films like call me by your
name for money we make them too upset
Mike Pence and like everyone in this
room and everyone watching at home we
are dreamers do all the dreamers out
there we stand with you well thank you
why so why were the Oscars on TV to
begin me to see the stars
now it's an off-site retreat for a
troubled industry something you might
accidentally walk into at a hotel
reception hall and so the stars don't
realize how bad they look when they try
to talk to America by crashing a nearby
theater
you are live on the Oscars right now
[Applause]
there's meryl streep who look like a hot
dog does anyone want a hot dog
let's fight do not aim the hot dogs at
the vegetarians are
yes so go ahead fire
[Music]
[Applause]
please welcome Tiffany Haddish and Maya
Rudolph Oh your beard smells delicious
uh we brought you some goodies you
peasants there's so much better than you
are
so as the Oscars try to explain why
movies matter you end up hating
everything about movies and that's not
fair to the movies it's short if you
hate the Oscars it's because you love
movies that's something Hollywood might
address but they won't